sehr kurze nacht für mich aber ich hoffe
man sieht es noch nicht so an den augen
wir haben schön gefeiert wenn es bei mir
auch nur ein bier war wohl wissend dass
heute noch viele termine auf mich dauern
wir sind alle sehr froh in mecklenburg
vorpommern dass die afg so einen
riesigen erfolg landen konnte wir haben
ja fast alle unsere wahlziele brothers
erreicht wir haben von anfang an gesagt
wir wollen über 20 prozent kommen
nun sind wir bei 21 gelandet sind damit
sehr zufrieden und das i-tüpfelchen ist
natürlich dass wir die cdu von platz
zwei verdrängt haben sie hinter uns
gelassen haben und wir damit jetzt
offensichtlich stärkste oppositionskraft
im schweriner landtag sein werden das
ist eine rolle die uns glaube ich liegt
und da werden wir der neuen regierung
auch ordentlich dampf machen
ja und ich glaube diese wahl war eben
wegen der schwäche der cdu oder der
stärke der afw wie immer sie wollen ein
klares signal nach berlin an die frau
bundeskanzler merkel ihre
migrationspolitik noch einmal zu
überdenken
wir haben das auf vielen
wahlveranstaltungen in mecklenburg
vorpommern genauso erlebt wir haben dort
natürlich unsere vielen
landespolitischen themen vorgestellt
aber wann immer wir in die diskussion
mit den bürgern getreten sind und das
haben wir gerne gemacht weil wir wissen
wollen wo der schuh drückt dann war das
eindeutig das bewegende thema der
menschen die offene scheunentore von
frau merkel
und sie hat nun sozusagen in dieser mann
kann es auch kleine bundestagswahl
nennen
sozusagen schon gehört und gemerkt wie
die bürger über ihre politik denken
wobei ich natürlich sagen möchte dass
sie es nicht alleine es ist natürlich
auch die politik der spd und der csu sie
bilden gemeinsam die große koalition in
berlin
ja ich glaube wir haben auch die
demokratie gestärkt als afd wir haben
die wahlbeteiligung deutlich erhöhen
können über zehn prozentpunkte damit
haben wir tatsächlich glaube ich einen
großen dienst erwiesen dass viele
menschen sich wieder politisch
interessieren weil es eben jetzt auch
mal wieder anders denkende in der
politik gibt auch in mecklenburg
vorpommern und das wollen die menschen
sie wollen alternativen diskutieren und
wollen sich ein vielseitiges bild der
meinungen machen und wenn viele
meinungen vorkommen dann stärkt das
natürlich die demokratie
das finden wir gut wir haben ja von den
nichtwählern 55.000 menschen holen
können bei dieser wahl das finde ich ist
ein sehr stolzes ergebnis und wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass die grünen aus dem
landtag geflogen sind und ich sage
bewusst wir haben dafür gesorgt dass wir
haben tatsächlich von den grünen sogar
3000 wähler bekommen das finde ich
persönlich auch ein bisschen erstaunlich
aber natürlich auch gut muss ich sagen
und wenn wir uns unsere wähler in
mecklenburg vorpommern anschauen dann
sehen wir dass wir eben nicht die partei
der modernisierungsverlierer oder der
abgehängten sind sondern dass wir breite
schichten der bevölkerung erreichen sehr
sehr viele arbeiter aber eben auch sehr
viele selbstständige
gerade die mittelständler sind es ja
auch in mecklenburg vorpommern die es
schwer haben zu bestehen die es schwer
haben nachwuchs zu bekommen weil die die
angehenden lehrlinge einfach nicht mehr
die fachlichen kompetenzen aus der
schule mitbringen stichwort bildung ein
großes problem bei uns in mecklenburg
vorpommern
ja und es zeigt sich auch dass wir quer
durch die alterstruktur ganz gut
aufgestellt sind besonders in den
mittleren jahrgängen also wir sind
tatsächlich volkspartei geworden in
mecklenburg vorpommern das ist also ein
guter start in unsere parlamentarische
arbeit
wir werden jetzt also stärkste kraft im
schweriner landtag sein und werden diese
kraft natürlich aus spielen wir werden
auch schnell in die puschen kommen dank
unserer anderen acht landtagsfraktionen
die wir bereits stellen in deutschland
und das heißt wir werden viele
unterstützung bekommen haben sie auch
schon in der planung bekommen auch vom
sächsischen landesverband beispielsweise
von unsere brandenburger freundin
bearbeiten wir sehr eng zusammen also
wir werden schon und schnell gut
aufstellen und es ist mir auch wichtig
zu sagen dass wir eben nicht die
fundamental opposition im landtag bilden
werden sondern wir werden konstruktiv
arbeiten das zeigt auch schon unser
wahlprogramm das sehr breit aufgestellt
ist und dazu dient auch diese dinge
jetzt anzusprechen und natürlich die
politik in unsere richtung zu treiben
also wir werden konstruktive kraft sein
im schweriner landtag das ist klar wir
wollen uns wirklich als echte
volkspartei etablieren in mecklenburg
vorpommern
ich hoffe mit diesem tollen ergebnis von
21 prozent haben wir auch eine gute
vorlage geliefert für die jetzt
anstehenden
ahlen die beiden vertreter sitzen ja
hier paul hampel jetzt in ein paar tagen
schon in niedersachsen mit der
kommunalwahl und die partie sg dann in
zwei wochen in berlin an die möchte ich
jetzt beide sozusagen den staffelstab
symbolisch heute übergeben herzlichen
dank
nach dem live ihre träume jetzt etwas
detaillierter über das ergebnis
berichtet hat würde ich ganz gern aus
bundes- sicht noch einige wenn sie sich
geeinigt haben sagen sie bescheid würde
ich ganz gern aus bundes- sicht noch
einige fakten und überlegungen ergänzen
es ist ja schon wieder erstaunlich dass
in der tat eine landesregierung die
angeblich bis vor kurzem noch 62 prozent
zustimmungswerte unter dem sellering
hatte dann doch ein historisch
schlechtes ergebnis bei der landtagswahl
einfährt
zwar schwankten die zustimmungswerte für
die spd je nach wahl in diesem
bundesland aber am ende gerade einmal 30
prozent zu erhalten ist unserer ansicht
nach keinen ritterschlag für ihre arbeit
und nun bleibt ihnen auch gar nichts
anderes übrig als wieder einmal in eine
große koalition zu gehen die so groß am
ende aber gar nicht mehr ist sondern
eben am ende um neun prozentpunkte in
der zustimmung insgesamt gesunken ist
das ist für die cdu natürlich umso
bitterer die haben das auch ehrlich
zugegeben weil man ja merkels stammland
ist
wir werden weiter daran arbeiten dass
sie diese stammland verliert was wir
diesmal schon geschafft haben sind drei
direktmandate zu holen
dass es für eine junge partei wie die
afg ein hervorragendes ergebnis
das war im vorpommern greifswald wo herr
weber und ohne kandidaten anteile auf
listenplatz nummer zwei unter stroscher
in diese mandate errungen haben und wir
freuen uns dass wir auf dieser ebene mit
den erststimmen bereits so viel
vertrauen der wähler geschenkt bekommen
haben
schaut man aber auf die analyse der
konkurrenz dann hat die cdu zwar eine
niederlage eingeräumt dennoch aber durch
ein tauber betonen lassen man habe ja
nichts falsch gemacht man habe die
politik nur nicht erklärt und diese
ignoranz die ist schon beispielhaft ist
nicht nur ignoranz zeigt sich hier in
auch eine fortgesetzte arroganz der
macht die sich aber nicht nur
in berlin bei der cdu manifestiert
sondern auch auf landesebene und das
während die cdu basis ihrer partei de
facto schon davon läuft
wir werden diesen erfolg kann
zweifelsohne nach berlin tragen am 18.09
und auch die kollegen auf der kommunalen
ebene in niedersachsen werden davon
profitieren dafür wünschen wir aus
bundes- sicht ein erfolg und werden uns
persönlich dafür einsetzen klar ist aber
auch dass berlin wo wir massive plakat
zerstörungen zu beklagen hatten ein
deutlich schweres wahlkampf umfeld noch
ist als mecklenburg vorpommern insofern
gebührt unseren kollegen hier vor ort
ein ganz besonders großer dank ich
möchte ganz gern vielleicht noch auf
zwei aspekte abheben gehören von der
politischen konkurrenz immer wieder
gestern abend von frau schwesig in der
runde der parteivorsitzenden in der ard
dass man jetzt unter den demokraten im
parlament einen schulterschluss suchen
werde und sie wissen ganz genau was
damit gemeint ist man glaubt immer noch
die afg als undemokratisch partei
bezeichnen zu können
das sagt unserer ansicht nach eine ganze
menge über das demokratieverständnis der
spd aber auch anderer parteien aus
vielleicht lassen sie sich einmal durch
den kopf gehen dass nach dem grundgesetz
in deutschland zugelassene parteien per
se demokratisch sind denn wenn sie
verboten werden vom
bundesverfassungsgericht dann dürfen sie
auch keine partei mehr sein dass an
dieser stelle glauben wir bewegt sich
die spd bewegt wege sich andere
parteivertreter der konkurrenz auf sehr
dünnem demokratischen als wenn sie
weiterhin behaupten sie seien die
demokraten und die afg sei es nicht ganz
zu schweigen davon was man damit über
die deutschen bürger aus sagt die eine
wahlentscheidung getroffen haben
wir bitten darum endlich aufzuhören
damit zwischen bürgern erster und
zweiter klasse zu unterscheiden indem
man glaubt die eine wahlentscheidung sei
moralisch oder politisch höherwertig als
eine andere im hinblick auf die
bundestagswahl möchte ich folgendes
sagen
entgegen vieler annahmen dass die
migrationspolitik die allergrößte rolle
bei diesem landtagswahlkampf gespielt
hat stellen wir fest und haben auch die
muss copen festgestellt
dass es fragen der sozialen
gerechtigkeit gewesen sind die die
bürger bewegt haben wie werden wir in
zukunft leben das fragt sich jeder
bürger in bezug auf die themen innere
sicherheit familie bildung das sind die
landesthemen wesentlichen gewesen
und wenn die bürger im nordosten sich
darüber beschweren dass eine
gebietsreform am ende ihren zugang zu
öffentlichen verwaltung erschwert dass
die schließung von elf amtsgerichten in
unserem nordöstlichsten bundesland
ebenfalls den weg zum rechtsstaat für
den einfachen bürger verlängert und wenn
durch die abschmelzung polizeikräften
die fahrt zum einsatzort die zeit bis
zum eingreifen der polizei massiv
verlängert wurde übrigens nicht nur in
mecklenburg vorpommern sondern wir
erleben dass in anderen bundesländern
auch dann sehen wir welche themen ist
sind die die bürger vor ort bewegt haben
und deswegen werden wir zur
bundestagswahl sicherlich unsere
kernthemen weiter propagieren den bürger
erklären und er sind die großen themen
euro-krise die frage wie gehen wir mit
europa und der eu um wie lösen wir die
probleme die aus einer ungesteuerten
illegale migration resultieren in bezug
auf die familienpolitik in bezug auf die
innere sicherheit
die kernthemen die wir den bürger immer
wieder vorstellen werden und ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal der afb dass wir
noch viel stärker positioniert sehen
wollen ist die frage wie viel
bürgerbeteiligung in deutschland
zukünftig möglich sein wird auf
landesebene haben diverse fraktionen
schon anträge gesetzesentwürfe
verfassungs verfassungsänderungen
eingebracht um die quoren für
bürgerbeteiligung regional zu senken
und wir werden weiter dafür kämpfen dass
es endlich volksentscheide auf
bundesebene gibt danke ich setze den
reigen dann mal fort zunächst mal ist es
mir ein großes bedürfnis auch nochmal
hier vor ihnen live ire colm ganz ganz
herzlich für diesen grandiosen erfolg zu
gratulieren
ich bin immer froh wenn irgendwo noch
besser ergebnis herauskommen als wir
sehen baden württemberg hatten und das
ist noch mal deutlich bessere werte mit
über 20 prozent ganz grandioses ergebnis
und dann gestern bei uns in baden
württemberg habe ich hier mit gefeiert
hatten
wahlparty war fast so groß wie eure
darum in schwerin freude allenthalben
ganz tolle sache und wir sehen meine
damen und herren das dass wir hier
wirklich eine echte alternative nun auch
in mecklenburg-vorpommern als neuntes
bundesland haben
das ist ein grandioser erfolg was mich
besonders gefreut hat
sie haben ja schon gesagt die
wahlbeteiligung ist um zehn
prozentpunkte gestiegen und das ist ein
sieg für die demokratie das ist erstmal
etwas was auch unsere kritiker
anerkennen müssen
die ist von knapp über 50 auf knapp über
60 prozent gestiegen das ist beileibe
nicht genug aber es ist ein deutlicher
fortschritt und man kann sehen dass wir
daran maßgeblichen anteil hatten wenn
55.000 bisherigen nichtwähler nun afd
gewählt haben dann ist es zunächst
einmal gelungen die an die wahlurne
überhaupt zurückzuholen
das ist wie man auch immer es ansonsten
inhaltlich bewertet ein erfolg für unser
land
ich will das in etwas grösseren kontext
stellen
es ist wohl unübersehbar dass sich unser
land in einem politischen umbruch
befindet und hier scheint mir das wort
nicht zu hoch gegriffen der historische
dimension hat die von uns so genannten
alt verteilen oder ich benutze noch
bevor zu dem begriff kartell parteien
wackeln erkennbar immer mehr und man
kann nicht übersehen dass wir dieses
land als alternative für deutschland
umkrempeln man stelle sich einmal vor wo
wir genau heute vor einem jahr standen
das war immer noch kurz nach dem essener
parteitag und da waren wir unterhalb der
fünf-prozent-hürde und schauen sie wo
wir heute stehen
dann kann man sagen wir sind inzwischen
volkspartei und der sind es nicht nur in
mecklenburg vorpommern als es ja völlig
erkennbar als zweitstärkste kraft
sondern wir sind in ganz deutschland
geworden und das ist uns in jahresfrist
gelungen
in gemeinsamer arbeit wir haben
zustimmung aus allen
bevölkerungsschichten sie können das
exemplarisch sehen an den
wählerwanderungen die kommen wirklich
aus allen teilen der gesellschaft
das ist also ein sehr umfassender
prozess und das ist auch wichtig das ist
aus all wirklich aus allen richtungen
kommen haben zustimmung aus seinen
linken von der spd von den grünen
weniger aber das sind ja auch nicht viel
in mecklenburg vorpommern cdu nicht
wieder überall her und das ist ein sehr
ermutigendes zeichen wenn man es in den
gesamtkontext einordnet muss man sagen
das war nun die neunte landtagswahl
hintereinander die als alternative für
deutschland gewonnen haben und die
ergebnisse sind erkennbar immer besser
und immer besser das ist eine klare
signalwirkung richtung berlin zunächst
einmal für die landtagswahl in zwei
wochen da wenn man das zehnte bundesland
haben indem wir im parlament vertreten
sind
es ist aber eben natürlich auch ein
klarer hinweis wo es in richtung
bundestagswahl hingehen ich denke das
interessiert sich natürlich in
besonderem maße es ist ein ganz ganz
klares signal und ich sage das in voller
überzeugung wir wollen langfristig in
diesem land regieren und diesen weg
gehen wir mal ehrlich unbeirrbar und
schritt für schritt immer weiter bis es
so weit sein wird und dabei ist ganz
ganz wichtig dass es ein weg ist der ein
programmatischer ein sachlicher ist dazu
haben wir uns in stuttgart in einem
bemerkenswerten bundesparteitag ein
programm gegeben das ganz wichtig
wirklich alle politikfelder umfasst in
23 müssen wir noch nachjustieren das
werden wir im nächsten parteitag machen
aber im wesentlichen haben wir ein
bundes parteiprogrammen dass alle
politikbereiche umfasst sollen wir uns
ja ganz gerne manchmal vorwirft ihre
weise das eine ein themen partei oder
sowas
das ist großer unsinn sondern wir sind
sehr breit aufgestellt und frauke petry
hat das völlig zu recht gesagt es sind
sehr stark sozialpolitische aspekte auch
die etwa bei diesen wahlen eine ganz
ganz große rolle spielen man immer
gesagt wird da geht es nur um das
migrations thema nein so ist das nicht
sondern auch die wirtschafts- und
sozialpolitischen geben spielen eine
große rolle
und hier beginnen die menschen zu
erkennen dass hier eine neue partei ist
die andere wege geht und die eine
kompetenz in diesen feldern hat und das
ist der grund warum wir erfolgreich sind
so viel von meiner seite weiter über den
staffelstab gerne von live ihre kolben
für niedersachsen kommende woche wir
wollen auf dem teppich bleiben
niedersachsen der kommunalwahlen die
wahl diesmal sehr stark von
bundespolitischen themen natürlich auch
von der migrations krise überlagert
werden wir glauben dass die finanziellen
auswirkungen auf die gemeinden in
niedersachsen sehr viel stärker sein
werden als man das in mancher kommune
derzeit erahnt
wir stellen fest dass genau wie in
mecklenburg vorpommern an sich eine
vertrauenskrise in die etablierten
parteien auch zum erfolg der hfg
beigetragen hat und die setzt sich fort
wir sind ebenfalls überzeugt davon dass
wir mit einer lösungsorientierten
kritischen begleiter politik in den
kreistagen und da wollen wir ja rein
auch in niedersachsen einiges bewirken
können vor allem aber eine sehr schwache
landesregierung angreifen können die ich
denke nur ein beispiel für uns ein
skandal dass der grösste konzern unseres
landes volkswagen von herrn weil und
seiner landesregierung aber auch vom
bund schmählich im stich gelassen wird
wenn es um einen nennen sie es nicht
abgab skandal nennen sie es ein
wirtschaftskrieg der usa gegen den
größten deutschen autokonzern geführt
wird da die handelnden alleine zu lassen
und damit hunderttausende von
arbeitnehmern in niedersachsen ist ein
starkes stück frau merkel weder frau
merkel noch her weil haben sich auch nur
ansatzweise vor den konzern gestellt um
größeren schaden abzuwenden
auch von den gewerkschaften hat man
erstaunlicherweise wenig die sind für
hunderttausende menschen in
niedersachsen verantwortlich dass sie in
den betriebsräten ihrer politik
durchsetzen können ein mann streitet
sich eher in wolfsburg das alles sind
keine guten zeichen für meine landsleute
in niedersachsen das wollen wir ändern
wir wollen bescheiden sein wir freuen
uns wenn wir ein zweistelliges ergebnis
in niedersachsen erreichen in den
kommunen sind wir noch nicht so stark
wir wollen in die kreistage einziehen
dann einen ersten flop dort setzten mit
2300 mitgliedern können sie 2650
bewerber stellen auch noch nicht zu
besetzen
aber wir gehen davon aus dass wir uns
dann in einer fünfjährigen phase der
opposition darauf vorbereiten dass wir
auch in den kommunen dann ende bei den
nächsten wahlen antreten und wir haben
uns vorgenommen 2017 natürlich aber vor
allem 20 18 bei den landtagswahlen in
niedersachsen so erfolgreich zu sein
dass wir den etablierten parteien dort
mehr als büro paroli bieten können
wohlgemerkt noch mal auch da in der
opposition über die nächste
legislaturperiode darauf sollten wir
dann diskutieren wenn es darauf ankommt
auf jeden fall wollen wir auch dort
regierungsverantwortung in zukunft
übernehmen nach einer guten und
intensiven und wichtigen für uns
wichtigen lernphase geschöpft
lassen sie mich auch noch ein paar worte
sagen zu berlin
zunächst mal möchte ich natürlich dem
leif erik holm ganz herzlich gratulieren
zu seinem tollen grandiosen ergebnis
er ist eine marke die duh vorgelegt hass
und wir werden uns anstrengen
zumindestens ranzukommen
aber berlin ist eben auch ein anderes
umfeld das muss man sehen auf der
anderen seite werden wir in berlin
wahrscheinlich zum ersten mal in die
lage versetzt werden tatsächlich
regierungsverantwortung übernehmen zu
müssen und zwar in den bezirken weil ja
das stadtrats amt in den bezirken kein
politisches amt ist sondern es ist ein
amt das nach dem deutschen verfahren
vergeben wird so dass wir davon ausgehen
dass wir ab dem 18
dann auch verantwortung politisch tragen
wir werden immer gefragt wollen sie den
mitregieren und es wird immer so
unterschwellig behauptet nein die fdp
will gar nicht mitregieren natürlich
wollen wir das aber sie haben sicherlich
schon wieder festgestellt dass herr
müller jetzt auf einmal in frage stellt
ob man das amt nicht politisch stellt so
dass die afg verhindert wird also wir
haben für uns in berlin ausgegeben wir
werden hier konstruktiv mitarbeiten wir
werden keine fundamental opposition sein
wir werden keine nein sager sein wir
werden alles das unterstützen was diese
stadt und dieses land voranbringt und
wir werden immer das wohl der bürger im
auge haben und das ist unser ziel
und da werden wir auch mit den parteien
zusammen aber die möglicherweise heute
noch nicht mit uns zusammenarbeiten
wollen
dankeschön
enercon osnabrücker zeitung zu dem
letzten thema helgoland hat ja gestern
noch einmal sehr deutlich gesagt dass er
die rolle der kfd als opposition sieht
auf keinen fall einer
regierungsbeteiligung anstrebt das
klingt bei ihnen anders
ich weiß nicht erbeuten wenn sie sagen
wir wollen regieren heißt dass auch wir
wollen mitregieren
fordern sie etwa die union oder andere
parteien auf ihnen gegenüber offener zu
sein
sie bezeichnen sich als volkspartei das
würde eigentlich einen solchen anspruch
nahelegen
also ich sags mal so wir fahren da nicht
mit den füßen sondern mit der schieren
zustimmung die wir bekommen stellt sich
die frage irgendwann von selbst
das wird kommen geld ganz von selbst uns
geht es nun nicht darum da bin ich bin
ich ganz bei einem gau land jetzt sofort
in irgendeiner regierungsverantwortung
hinein zu drängen aber wenn eine partei
zunächst zweistellig wird dann im einer
und im zweier bereich sind und wir
wissen ja nicht wie das weitergeht dann
wird man irgendwann an dieser partei
nicht mehr umhin können weil man
irgendwann keine regierung mehr ohne
diese verteilt werden können
und dann werden wird sich diese frage
stellen
ich werde hier keine aussage dazu machen
wann das der fall sein wird idealerweise
wird das schon bei der bundestagswahl
der fall sein aber dass das werden wir
dann sehen
es ist aber so dass wir natürlich eine
partei in dieser größenordnung die wir
sie mittlerweile erreicht haben und wir
werden weiter arbeiten werden nicht
ignorieren können und kann nicht sein
dass eine politische partei dauerhaft
sagt wir sind überhaupt nicht bereit
regierungsverantwortung zu übernehmen
das geht nicht ich meine da für man man
tritt politisch an um verantwortung zu
übernehmen um zu gestalten
das ist die aufgabe einer partei das
gilt auch für uns und diese aufgabe wird
sich wird sich irgendwann ganz von
selber stellen und wir müssen das gar
nicht gar nicht bevor wir müssen auch
keine anderen parteien ansprechen das
kommt das muss man mit einer gewissen
grund gelassenheit angehen und ich denke
die haben wir
nicht läuft das kcv petra mountain ist
hersteller zwischen ihnen lange zeit der
sprachlosigkeit zumindest nach außen hin
heute sehe ich sich seit monaten das
erste mal wieder zusammen ist das
sozusagen auf das erkenntnis dass sie da
wieder zusammenarbeiten werden als also
um mecklenburg vorpommern hat die beiden
geeint wenn eine partei zwei sprecher
hat und das sind sehr unterschiedliche
charaktere
dann ist es völlig normal dass es auch
mal dass auch mal disput und ist der
dissens in der sache gibt der war da und
es geht nicht darum nun sozusagen die
habe es nicht gegeben
ich habe es in etlichen interviews auch
schon gesagt das ist aber soweit ein
völlig normaler vorgang dass ich eher
beängstigend finde ist wenn man das
alles immer zu deckeln wenn es nur eine
meinung geben darf also für mich ist
etwas tiefer störendes gewesen dieser
cdu parteitag im dezember letzten jahres
ich spreche ja immer von duracell
klatsch häschen die macher neun minuten
bestellten applaus für frau merkel und
findet überhaupt keinen diskurs statt
wir haben uns mal gestritten das ist
bekannt und wir haben uns auch wieder
zusammengerauft das nicht das erste mal
dass wir uns begegnet wir sind und
seither mehrfach begegnet und das ist
eine ausgeräumte geschichten und wir
sind in einer völlig normalen
zusammenarbeit kollegialen
zusammenarbeit miteinander
das finden sie wahrscheinlich weitaus
überraschender als wir das finden wir
halten das für einen völlig normalen
vorgang habe ich gar nichts hinzuzufügen
ja eine frage an herrn wollten ihre
fraktion ist ja im landtag von baden
württemberg noch gespalten sie haben ja
mediator eingesetzt man rechnen sie denn
damit weil sie gerade erzählt haben von
der wunderbaren wahlparty die sie dort
auch im sinn veranstaltet haben dass sie
ihre fraktionen wieder zusammenführen
können also heute sind wir hier um uns
über das wahlergebnis mecklenburg
vorpommern zone halten und darauf
sollten wir uns konzentrieren
sie sagen selbst die mediation läuft wir
haben darüber stillschweigen vereinbart
daran werde ich mich auch halten gehen
sie davon aus dass soll mein einziger
satz hat zu sein dass das auf gutem weg
ist und dass wir noch in diesem monat
mit resultaten werden aufwarten können
das wäre zu kommen eine nachfrage
erneuten sie haben ebenfalls um die
frage der regierungsbeteiligung ging
haben sie 2017 als eine option genannt
heißt dass 2017 als mögliche
regierungsbeteiligung der
bundesregierung an der an einer
bundesregierung könnte ein ziel für die
afg werden
sie sehen ja exemplarisch was ich bin
jahresfrist tun kann wenn sie sehen wo
wir heute vor einem jahr standen und wo
wir jetzt stehen
wenn wir jetzt ein jahr weiter denken
wenn wir september 2017 haben und dann
wird gewählt werden und da muss man
sehen was da beim wahlergebnis rauskommt
und dann kann man darüber reden was sich
da ergeben werde ich würde das für eine
völlig sinnfreie spekulation halten
darauf jetzt zu antworten wir streben
das und das an wir müssen sehen wo wir
dann stehen und wenn wenn sich unsere
unser erfolgskurs weiter fortsetzt dann
wird sich die frage eventuell stellen
das werden aber dann sehen
bis zur nächsten wahl bundestagswahl
insbesondere dass sich die
flüchtlingskrise ja ein stück weit ins
schärfen der migrations strom wird
nachlassen es werden die flüchtlinge
unterkunft finden
durch welches andere thema wollen sie
denn dieses thema dann ersetzen wenn es
vielleicht doch dann irgendwann mal
nicht mehr so zieht wie es jetzt in
diesem jahr abgezogen hat
herr stephan das stimmt ja jetzt auch
schon ich das haben wir eingangs schon
gesagt in diesem landtagswahlkampf war
das thema migrations krise eines von
mehreren weil sich landes von
bundesthemen die abkoppeln lassen aber
die affäre in allen vergangenen
wahlkämpfen auch mal mit
landespolitischen themen argumentiert
und im übrigen teile ich ihre euphorie
dazu dass die auswirkungen der illegalen
migration sich bis 2017 erledigt haben
mitnichten denn das thema
familiennachzug ist nicht geklärt das
thema illegale einwanderung über nicht
ausreichend kontrolliert grenzen ist
nicht geklärt das thema wann halten wir
uns wieder ein dublin 3 ist nicht
geklärt die frage wie man im
europäischen kontext damit umgeht ist
nicht geklärt wie wir mit flüchtlingen
auf mittelmeer umgehen schicken wir sie
zurück oder holen sie de facto mit eu
gesponserten taxis nach europa ist nicht
geklärt also ich glaube das sind genug
punkte um diese hypothese vielleicht ein
bisschen mit vorsicht zu behandeln
unternehmen habe ich ihnen folgendes
ausgeführt mit welchen themen wir den
bundestagswahlkampf im wesentlichen
gestalten werden weil sie sich förmlich
aufdrängen
und weil am ende der bürger entscheidet
welche themen relevant sind und nicht
einzelne parteien oder fiebrig eine
frage an herrn kaspersky sie haben's ja
gerade schon angesprochen dass sie eben
den eindruck haben dass keiner in berlin
mit ihnen zusammenarbeiten möchte was
glauben sie ist in die motivation der
anderen das eben nicht zu tun was da
dahinter steckt wie bewerten sie das
ja ich werde das so dass man
offensichtlich versucht darüber die afg
aus dem parlament heraus zu halten
sie wissen es gibt ja einen konsens
gegen rechts ein konsens gegen links
geht es nicht beispielsweise es ist die
angst um eigene posten und pöstchen es
ist die angst um die eigenen freunde und
deshalb versucht man die afg überall
dort draußen zu halten wo man es nur
kann
das wird ihnen aber nicht gelingen den
parteien und ich sehe auch dass die die
tage von herrn müller und herrn henkel
gezählt sind wenn ich mir die
wahlergebnisse an gruppe die
meinungsumfragen dann bin ich sicher
dass in der cdu und der spd unmittelbar
nach der wahl sofort die personalfrage
gestellt wird also ich werde mich auf
neue person einstellen müssen wenn ich
dann opposition im abgeordnetenhaus hier
in berlin machen werde
ich habe eine frage an herrn holm und
zwar frau petri hatte ja herrn weber
erwähnt der jetzt in der fraktion
gewählt wurde der professor in
greifswald und hat offenbar ein
bekennender neonazi promoviert herrn
bunzel schließen sie denn aus dass sich
bei ihnen neuer fall gedeon entwickeln
könnte wo es auf einen
fraktionsausschluss hinausläuft
das schließe ich aus also ist mir nicht
bekannt wenn sie die promotion des
studenten dort ansprechen da habe ich
entweder sehr stark verteidigt denn es
kann ja nicht sein dass die politische
gesinnung darüber entscheidet ob jemand
drum promovieren kann also das spielt
überhaupt keine rolle in einer
wissenschaftlichen diskussion kann keine
rolle spielen
alles andere wäre undemokratisch und
einem rechtsstaat unwürdig freiheit der
lehre
sie hatten ja vor der wahl andere glaube
ich auch den sogenannten schweriner weg
ein wenig verlassen was die
zusammenarbeit mit der npd angeht wie
verhält sich das jetzt nach der wahl
werden sie die npd ist ja abgemahnt
worden weil sie sich deutlicher als
bisher von der npd distanzieren ich
glaube deutlicher als ich mich von
dieser partei distanziert haben kann man
sich davon gar nicht distanzieren und
zwar vor der wahl die nach der wahl nach
der wahl stellt sich diese frage
glücklicherweise nicht mehr was übrigens
ein erfolg ist den wahrscheinlich nahezu
alle menschen mut finden werden wir auf
das ist ein wirklicher erfolg diese
partei ist nicht mehr im parlament
vertreten
ich habe aber in rede steht er dieses
interview mit dem mannheimer morgen
zu keinem zeitpunkt je gesagt was dann
die schlagzeilen brachten ich schließe
eine kooperation mit mit diesen
extremisten nicht aus und eine
zusammenarbeit und dann packt ihren usw
das wurde nie gesagt sondern ich habe
das gleiche gesagt was er auch gesagt
hat dass wir bei parlamentarischen
initiativen immer in der sache
entscheiden werden und ich habe gesagt
dass es völlig egal von wem die
initiative kommt die könnte auch von der
linken kommen
es hat sonderbare weise aber niemand
geschrieben daraufhin die afg effekt
eine kooperation mit der linken
hätte man ebenso schreiben können wir
sagen wir machen eine politik im sinne
der bürger und dafür sind wir
verpflichtet dafür sind wir in die
parlamente gewählt
und egal welche partei ist ist wenn ein
vernünftiger vorschlag ist dann werden
wir dem zustimmen das halten wir für
richtig und ich bemerke diese
stigmatisierung übrigens auch im baden
württembergischen landtag ein stück weit
egal was was die afg vorschlägt es wird
boykottiert weil es von der afg kommt
das ist ein ganz wunderbares
demokratieverständnis sondern man muss
doch in der sache beurteilen was man
machen nicht mehr als das habe ich
gesagt also wenn man mir jetzt nahelegt
ich hätte damit eine fehlende abgrenzung
zu dieser partei gemacht hat ist das
völlig falsch die abgrenzung ist völlig
klar und ich habe das auch immer wieder
deutlich gemacht
also vielleicht ergänzend dazu aus
mecklenburg vorpommern herrmann hat es
genau korrekt wiedergegeben was unsere
position in mecklenburg vorpommern ist
es gibt keine zusammenarbeit mit der npd
jetzt ist es sowieso hinfällig aber auch
das haben wir vorher gesagt ein
eigentlich ein klarer satz den man gar
nicht missverstehen kann
wir haben wie gesagt herr morgen hatte
schon ausgeführt tatsächlich nur gesagt
dass vier sache anträge der sache
nachbarn
sie kommt mehr war es nicht marco k 10
24 mit dem aktuellen x ergebnis haben
sie natürlich auch ein paar große
parteien geärgert
was wäre denn je fünf an die großen
parteien
was müssen die dann machen damit die afg
wieder wähler wieder zurück zu den
großen parteien kommen wir erwarten ja
nicht ernsthaft dass wir frau merkel
sagen wie die politik zu machen oder
herr gabriel das ist deren eigene
aufgabe und wenn spd und cdu kein
besseres personal zu bieten haben als
derzeit dann ist auch deren probleme
also die afd hat von anfang an ihre
themen gewählt und gefunden das es
ehemals themen der großen etablierten
parteien gewesen sind diese aber lange
gerade von der cdu verlassen wurden
ist ja letztlich die geburtsstunde der
afg gewesen und zu glauben dass eine cdu
die inhaltlich und personell durch frau
merkel entfernt wurde jetzt kurzfristig
auf diesem weg zurückfindet halten wir
für sehr unwahrscheinlich deswegen war
es richtig davon zu reden dass in
mecklenburg vorpommern möglicherweise
der anfang vom ende der cdu besiegelt
wurde
aber das ist normal im politischen
geschäft und ich finde wir sollten
aufhören es zu bedauern wenn parteien
verschwinden und parteien neu entstehen
schauen sie mal in das mutterland der
demokratie in die schweiz da sind partei
spaltungen neugründungen und fusionen
sehr viel mehr an der tagesordnung als
bei uns und wir glauben dass so etwas
demokratische geschäft belebt bei
etablierte strukturen immer zur
verkrustung neigen und deswegen ist
dieser prozess ein völlig normaler und
die bürger empfinden ich glaub ich auch
als weitaus normaler als die betroffenen
parteien weil es eben darum inhalte und
weniger um funde geht aber sie haben mit
ihrer bemerkung natürlich recht wenn sie
sagen dass bei der spd wie aber auch bei
der cdu die menschen inzwischen die
frage stellen wo stehen sie inhaltlich
und personell und inzwischen glaube ich
dass aus der union nur noch ein gebäude
oder ein gebäude übrig geblieben ist das
steht noch das die ganze konzentration
des gebäudes ist noch da in jedem
fenster
hängt ein bild von angela merkel wenn
sie das gebäude reinschauen ist weder
inhaltlich noch personell noch was drin
und dass das auf dauer in den nächsten
jahren zu einem abschmelzen im
konservativ freiheitlichen lager für die
union kommen wird und ich überzeugt
davon bin ich hab das mal auf der brücke
sagt der noz ich halte uns für die
natürliche nachfolgepartei der
christlich demokratischen union
deutschlands und wenn die cdu mit diesem
ergebnis in mecklenburg vorpommern und
so weiter macht in den anderen ländern
ähnlich schlecht frisiert und dann wie
die spd vielleicht auf 12 und 13 prozent
absackt sind sie nicht nur keine
volkspartei mehr sie sind nicht mehr die
bestimmende kraft in diesem lande und
dann sind wir die natürliche
nachfolgepartei der cdu kurz sagen die
cdu geht den weg der övp hat ja gesagt
nach den landtagswahlen im märz hier in
diesem hause kfd dass die partei des
sozialen friedens sein
danach wurde ein programm beschlossen in
dem es heißt geld vom staat und der grip
die selbständigkeit des bürgers und
jeder solle künftig möglichst auf
privater basis vorsorgen es ging ja auch
ins arbeitslosengeld
ich würde mal interessieren wie sie das
mit ihrem sozialen anspruch im einklang
bringen wollen
da wäre es schön wenn sie das programm
wirklich gelesen hätten herr steffen
denn so wie sie es gerade kolportierter
im stimmt ja nicht denn wir haben ja
diverse aspekte im grundsatzprogramm
bereits verankert die zeigen dass uns
gesellschaftliche solidarität sehr
wichtig ist auch wenn wir vielleicht den
ansatz immer mehr staat für den falschen
halten und deswegen ist es gut wenn eine
partei die diskussion führt wie viel
staat wie für solidarität wir in diesem
land tatsächlich brauchen und wir sie
mitnichten dafür dass alles privatisiert
wird nur da wo der staat immer mehr dem
bürger die verantwortung abnimmt bleibt
am ende wenig bürgerliche freiheit übrig
und das definitiv nicht gut das mute
daneben mehr nach ökologischem
sozialismus aller merkel ein
als nach einer sozialen marktwirtschaft
eine frage an frau petri parteien treten
ja normalerweise auch mit gesichter mit
den wahlkampf jetzt auf den
bundestagswahl gesprochen
sind sie bereit spitzenkandidaten für
die bundestagswahl kampf der afc zu
werden und wenn ja wann würde das
geklärt sie wissen genau dass ich auf
diese frage heute keine antwort bekommen
als erstes eine interne angelegenheit
der partei ist und zum thema
landtagswahlkampf mecklenburg vorpommern
definitiv nicht gehört würde ich direkt
eine frage einer erneuten anschließen ob
sie denn frauke petry als
spitzenkandidaten mittlerweile
unterstützen würden und eine frage an
herrn holm und frau petri herr holm hat
im wahlkampf wörtlich gesagt wir wollen
nicht dass die politiker deutschland und
europa schritt für schritt für schritt
zu einem kalifat machen ob sie diese
ängste die sie da haben noch mal konkret
begründen können also dann wird viel
raum für die beantwortung von holm sein
weil ich ganz ganz kurz machen
sie erwarten doch nicht ernsthaft eine
antwort auf diese frage genau so wie
frau petra auf die frage davor keine
antwort heutige werde ich darauf keine
geben sondern wir werden das zu
geeigneter zeit und die ist jetzt nicht
und nicht hier und heute in den
parteigremien klären
okay die kalifat frage die
meistgestellte frage glaube ich im
wahlkampf
es ist natürlich so dass in mecklenburg
vorpommern dieses problem noch nicht so
existiert aber die menschen verfolgen
natürlich das geschehen und sehen dass
sich immer größere
parallelgesellschaften bilden
in den westdeutschen großstädten in
berlin und wir sehen eben frau merkels
politik mit ungesicherten grenzen mit
unkontrollierter zuwanderung und dafür
haben die menschen angst wir führen
diese ängste nicht sondern wir greifen
die ängste auf die die bundesregierung
durch ihre politik verursacht
und wir müssen eben darüber reden dass
wir probleme tatsächlich mit manchen
menschen haben in diesem land die einem
fundamentalistischen islam an hängen
also studien ergeben ja eine große
studie in ganz europa in mehreren
ländern europas auf jeden fall hat eben
gezeigt dass das die hälfte der dort
befragten muslime tatsächlich die
scharia höhe hängt als die gesetzgebung
unserer länder
und das natürlich ein problem und über
das müssen wir einfach reden und das
haben wir auch in jeder veranstaltung
gemerkt dass es für die menschen ein
thema ist also lassen sie uns darüber
reden und wege finden wie wir das
problem lösen aber lassen sie mich zu
dem punkt bei ihnen ein beispiel nennen
es muss nicht gleich immer die
islamistisch extremistischen richtung
sein sondern wenn sie wie zum beispiel
in frankfurt offenbach einen islamischen
anteil von ungefähr 30 bis 35 prozent in
einer stadt in einer kommune haben dann
gehen sie meine stadt holen da war ich
unlängst und habe mir das ulmer münster
angeschaut und diese über münster ist
renovierungsbedürftig die brauchen 25
millionen euro um das münster wieder im
alten glanz erstrahlen zu lassen ich
habe sehr lange in im orient in asien
gelebt ich kenne die kultur und dort ich
weiß auch dass man zum beispiel zu alten
gebäuden nicht also einen bezug hat wie
das in europa der fall ist beste
beispiel das wohnhaus mohammeds hat man
in den 60er jahren problemlos abgerissen
kein grund also aufrecht zu erhalten und
dort ein neues haus dorthin gesetzt
wenn sie jetzt noch einen anderen
religiös kulturellen hintergrund haben
und dann haben sie eine wirkungskette
anteil von 30 40
muslimen in ulm dann wird er vielleicht
noch mal in das schöne ulmer münster
gehen wenn ihnen aufruf sieht wir
brauchen 25 millionen gästen seien es
die ich meine glaubensgruppe und
verhaltens für kann man für das alte
gemäuer schüler aus hinsetzen
dann ist das der kulturelle unterschied
den wir haben und ich werfe das dem
weder dem einen noch dem anderen vor
aber die bürger in diesem lande müssen
sich bewusst werden dass in dem
augenblick wo in gemeinden eine fee hat
oder ein großer anteil anderer
kultureller und religiöser hintergründe
lebt ist ein problem geben kann diese
gemeinde alleine in ihrem ist zustand
wie sie heute ist in der form aufrecht
zu erhalten und ich glaube darüber
denken viele menschen gar nicht machte
sich natürlich eine kulturelle
veränderung ergeben wird und die
menschen in deutschland darüber
entscheiden ob wir das wollen oder nicht
wir sehen uns alle am 19